earlier this week call of duty publisher
Activision removed a game from steam
because it featured allegedly stolen
black ops three gun assets I'm Lucy and
welcome to your put that back gamespot
news update the theft was brought to
light shortly after a ryan developer
david purcell released a post on the
game steam forums asking people to rise
up and protest a dmca takedown notice
from activision however press l has
since updated the post saying that he
got proof from activation which made the
stolen assets immediately apparent you
wrote last night I received evidence
directly from Activision regarding
assets not even mentioned in public yet
upon receiving this it became
immediately apparent that blatant trips
were made while the artist offered to
remake any assets at no cost he has now
been fired immediately upon learning
this this will slightly affect
production and I will get into that
later the similarities between the two
games assets were first made apparent by
neogaf user logie who shared a
comparison image of the guns bracel and
some of the community were under the
assumption that these comparisons were
the only infractions until Purcell
received the aforementioned evidence
from Activision press L said this
occurred because his company track
industries hires remote developers who
live in different time zones and work
different hours of the day he added that
he doesn't design the weapons and can't
cross check freelancers work with every
other game he wrote I don't get to play
all the games I am working on this
full-time well that's all well and good
but this isn't the only time this has
happened with Orion press L himself
notes for instances where stolen assets
were used in the game including armor
from natural selection to artwork from
primal carnage audio from counter-strike
and achievement images which press L
himself took responsibility for press L
ended the post saying that the team
needed to bunker down and work on
replacing the stolen assets it seems
like they have as a Ryan is now back on
stage
so what do you make of it all was it an
innocent mistake that happened four
times or are they just upset that they
got caught let me know in the comments
below I'll come find me on Twitter I met
Lucy James games for more gaming news
make sure you keep it gamespot
you